Okay, before we get started today, I must
give you two warnings:
The first one is that we might include some
spoilers about Narcos, obviously.
But, given that this is a TV show based on
real history, I don’t think this is that
much a problem.
The second warning is that today we are going
to talk about drug trafficking...
A topic where the information we have is incomplete
and, at all the time police are finding new
bits of information that could prove parts
of this video wrong.
This being said…
Colombia is known as the “country of a thousand
rhythms”, the country of coffee.
and the birthplace of many of those latino
singers that got the whole world to dance...
Nevertheless, what really made this country
famous is, sadly, this man…
The king of cocaine.
The man who basically created one of the world’s
most dangerous industries…
At the end of the 1980s, Pablo Escobar, or
‘EL PATRON´, as his neighbours used to
know him, controlled 90% of the worldwide
production of cocaine.
Suddenly, Medellin, a city of 2 million inhabitants,
became the Hollywood of cocaine.
However, on December the first, 1993, he died
during a shootout with the police.
But you probably already knew that...
So the question now becomes: What happened
after?
Who took Pablo Escobar’s business?
And then there is the most important question
of all…
Is there still cocaine trafficking in Colombia?
Well, today, we are gonna answer all of those
questions… but before we get into all of
that, let’s talk a little bit about cocaine…
After weed, cocaine is the second most consumed
drug in the world.
But, unlike the first one, cocaine is extremely
hard to find.
Marijuana grows anywhere on the planet - even
in cold places like North America.
Grow houses are found all the time… with
just a little bit of expenditure, anyone can
create, at home, the optimal conditions for
growing cannabis.
But coca leaves are a different animal.
You need a very specific habitat.
This is why only some countries can grow it.
The main ones are Colombia, Peru and Bolivia...
In other words, there is space for just a
few suppliers but the demand won’t stop
growing - and it’s a global demand.
This is why cocaine is such a high profit
business, and this is why, right after Pablo
Escobar’s death, there were lots of people
willing to take his place.
MAFIA WARS
As you know, Pablo Escobar was the leader
of the Medellin cartel.
But, even before his death, there was already
a second cocaine capital, and this was the
city of CALI, also in Colombia and with very
similar population.
The
Cali cartel wanted to take the whole of Pablo
Escobar’s business.
But Medellin had plenty of narcos wanting
to do the same thing.
One of them was DIEGO FERNANDEZ MURILLO, A.K.A.
Don Berna.
Don Berna helped the police deal with Pablo
Escobar, made an alliance with the Cali Cartel,
and even had close ties with a right-wing
paramilitary group called the Colombian Self
Defense Forces.
With Pablo Escobar dead and buried, Don Berna
started a new organization with this paramilitary
group, the so-called OFICINA DE ENVIGADO.
At the same time, all the little Narcos in
Medellin where also fighting for their share
of the cake.
This street you see here was the border between
one band and the other.
Basically, if you were a worker for the OFICINA
DE ENVIGADO and crossed this street, someone
would kill you immediately.
So, as you can imagine, these were extremely
violent times for the city - different drug
bands were killing each other all the time.
Meanwhile, the Cali cartel was way more subtle...
This is GILBERTO RODRIGUEZ and his partner,
PACHO HERRERA.
They were high class boys, with plenty of
contacts among politicians and judges.
In fact, Gilberto Rodriguez paid over $6 million
to finance the campaign of one of the Colombian
presidents, Ernesto Samper.
Nonetheless, despite the influence and the
corruption, after sometime the inevitable
happened…
‘The government has started the extradition
process for the chief of the Cali Cartel’
Nonetheless, Don Berna, violent as he was,
had a totally different story.
Actually, among all the characters that appear
on the Narcos TV show, Don Berna is the one
who has lasted the longest without being put
behind bars.
But… wait just a minute because now we are
going to talk about the characters that didn’t
appear on the show!
At least, in the first two seasons!
And… prepare yourself because there is a
lot to tell.
Do you remember how Don Berna worked with
this right wing group?
Well… the political ideology was more important
than what you might think.
The Colombian Self Defenses Forces were born
to fight against communist guerrillas in the
country…
FUERZAS ARMADAS REVOLUCIONARIAS DE COLOMBIA
- FARC
FARC is more than a simple terrorist group.
In some areas of the country, they became
a parallel government.
More than an Al Qaeda kind of thing, they
could better be compared with DAESH, or Islamic
State.
Even today, a good part of the Colombian rainforest
is under the control of this Marxist-Leninist
group.
FARC had their own doctors, their own hospitals
and, of course, they collected their own ‘taxes’.
‘Estimations say this Group has over 20,000
members spread among 24 of the 32 provinces
Colombia has’
As you can imagine, FARC were not good friends
of drug trafficking.
Yes, both, drug traffickers and terrorist
had common enemies... but the idea of becoming
a millionaire by selling a product on the
international market doesn’t sound very
Marxist, right?
Besides, extortion and kidnapping is a very
lucrative business as well, and FARC, well
they were experts on these matters.
Add to this the fact that DON BERNA and his
OFICINA de ENVIGADO had an anti-communist
group on their side and you can imagine the
war that was about to happen...
‘This is the BOJAYA municipality, today
it’s covered by plants and trees.
That is the North part, from where FARC launched
the rockets to the other part of the municipality’
But business is business.
No matter the money FARC could make with kidnapping…
it was hard to resist to the temptation of
drug trafficking.
So one day, MEDINA CARACAS, one of the main
FARC leaders, decided to try the cocaine business.
‘The 16th front of the FARC, went from 200
members to over 800 thanks to the income of
the cocaine that became a main source to finance
the guerrillas’
Don’t forget that FARC had the control of
all the areas where coca plantations where.
In fact, they had already extorted the growers...
Nonetheless, with Medina Caracas as leader,
FARC created their own fields and their own
distribution networks.
This was all happening by the year 2000.
At this time, the Cali cartel was already
dismantled.
But cocaine was still employing a good share
of the Colombian workforce...
So, to summarise, on one hand, we have the
OFICINA de ENVIGADO with DON BERNA as a leader,
then we have FARC on the other hand and…
between these two, there was a plethora of
independent drug trafficking bands called
the BACRIM.
It was during this time that Colombia chose
a new president, ALVARO URIBE.
URIBE was born in Medellin and his main political
goal was to end all the violence.
And this marked the beginning of the…
PAX MAFIOSA
Alvaro Uribe was ready to end the guerrilla
warriors and the right wing groups at any
cost.
This is why, in the year 2005, his defense
minister, CAMILO OSPINA, signed a law that
is thought of with sadness in Colombia.
This was “Directive 029”.
And now you might be wondering…
Well, why is that sad?
This directive said, literally, that the Government
would give the equivalent of $1900 to anyone
who would murder a guerrilla warrior or a
paramilitary right wing fighter.
Basically, if you were a soldier in the Colombian
army and you wanted to have a good career,
all you had to do was get out and go on a
man hunt.
And all of a sudden, the death toll at FARC
and among narcos, skyrocketed.
But hold on a minute because this was just
the beginning...
Finding FARC members was not an easy job.
But, the reward given by the Colombian government
was really really tempting...
This is why a lot of soldiers started killing
innocent civilians.
After that, they would dress them with a FARC
uniform and take a picture of the dead body.
This was enough to go the the government office
and get the money.
And this happened more than once or twice.
There is even a name for it in Colombia.
The dead civilians were called ‘false positives’
and it became a major way for people to make
money in Colombia.
Still today, the Colombian justice system
has over 3000 ongoing cases of ‘false positives’
that need investigating.
But, wait a minute…
The policies of President Uribe were extremely
controversial.
But one thing has to be said… he made it
way more complicated for FARC guerrilla warriors.
Raids on cocaine fields and distribution networks
became the norm.
And when your enemy is killing dozens of your
members, you are willing to sign an alliance
with the devil himself…
Some emails prove the links between FARC and
the narcos.
In one of the messages, EMIRO CONEJO, a guerrilla
leader, shows clear connections with the OFICINA
DE ENVIGADO.
As we said before, FARC weere present at all
the plantations.
In some cases, those plantations belonged
to the Oficina de Envigado or some belonged
to the BACRIM we mentioned earlier.
On the other hand, some plantations were managed
directly by FARC.
These are where they grew and processed coca
leaves and turned them into white powder.
Then, the big cartels stepped in to distribute
the cocaine to countries.
Nonetheless, unlike the times of Pablo Escobar,
Colombian cartels no longer have a monopoly
over distribution.
For instance, when those Colombian narcos
want to send cocaine to US, they partner with
Mexican drug dealers.
When they want to send it to Europe, they
work with Italian, Greek and Albanian mafias.
But we are going to talk all about that in
another video!
The important thing is, despite the fact that
drug trafficking is still a thing today, Medellin
is now a peaceful city.
Of course, they still have bad neighbourhoods
where it’s better not to go, especially
on the outskirts of the city.
But the city has made a big change.
A change for better.
This ‘pax mafiosa’ has allowed all the
players involved with the cocaine business
to make an agreement so each of them has their
territories and they have no reason to kill
each other.
Yep, now cocaine is easier to find than ever…
but less people die during
the process.
And now you might be wondering…
Well, what can will happen now that FARC have
made a peace agreement with the Colombian
Government?
Well, this could become an opportunity for
the BACRIM to take back the control of the
business that is now in the guerrilla's hands...
But the truth is, those narcos are trying
now to get another peace agreement with the
government as profitable as the one FARC are
negotiating.
Crazy as it sounds, FARC claim to be a political
group...
their ideology, their propaganda and even
their website, it’s all politics.
Their website can be visited by anyone.
This is why they sit with the government as
equals.
However, the BACRIM are seen as ordinary criminals,
with no politics or ideology whatsoever…
And, of course, those narcos are wondering…
Why can FARC can talk with the government
and we can’t?
The agreements between FARC and the government
are extremely good for the guerrillas.
And, once again, everyone wants a piece
of the cake.
But… that’s another story.
Now it is your turn.
Do you think it is possible to end the trafficking
of cocaine?
Or do you think it’s a matter that each
time a band is dismantled, a new one appears?
Well, please, leave your answers in the comments
section below.
You can also visit the RECONSIDER MEDIA PODCAST.
They provided the voices on this video that
are not mine.
Also don’t forget that we publish brand
new videos every Monday and every Thursday
so don’t forget to subscribe so you won’t
miss any post.
If you like this video, give us a thumbs up
and… as always, I’ll see you in the next
video!